home alcohol and elidio see themselves
as a band of merry men planning a daring
jump over the barriers to get a free
ride on the commuter train they know
they're risking a fine
so they take precautions most people go
through the barriers here in the hall
but we don't want to draw attention to
ourselves
so we're better off going around the
other side there are fewer people and
there's less chance of getting caught a
monthly pass for the route between every
and Paris costs 113 euros and that's
more than these young men are willing to
pay the prices are a ripoff and I don't
say that just because I'm broke I don't
think it's right that you should have to
pay so much for public transport it
should be free it should be completely
paid for with taxpayers money to me
riding without a ticket is an act of
civil disobedience
flaw is a student and lives with his
parents in another Paris suburb he takes
the train every day my parents know I
don't buy a ticket they worry about me
and sometimes they give me money to get
one but they can't always afford it on
some of the trains in the French capital
around one third of passengers are
travelling without a valid ticket Pierre
cadeaux was the mayor of a town outside
Paris and spent years trying to tackle
the problem he says bringing back
station staff instead of ticket machines
would help I don't own a cassette that
people who are paying for tickets see
all these people jumping over the
barriers and it makes them wonder why
they're paying this is the new normality
it's no longer normal to pay it's normal
not to pay what used to be a bit of
provocation has become a sport and it's
ticket inspectors who are bearing the
brunt some young fare Dodgers travel in
groups and tend to get aggressive the
inspectors tactic is to deflect the
tension by showing they trust the public
even when they're dealing with obvious
offenders this young woman claims she's
left her monthly student pass at home if
you forgotten your past that can produce
it later over there at the station then
you only need to pay 6 euros it's a fair
solution she says fair Dodgers are
customers so my job is to make sure they
become good customers
in France people don't just dodge fairs
because they don't want to pay it's a
national tradition even former president
Chuck Chuck one slept over the barriers
with obvious enjoyment some pompous I
don't find that shocking the barrier was
broken it just goes to show how athletic
he was it doesn't shock me in the least
shock might not have been deliberately
fair dodging but the incident is
legendary nonetheless an illegal student
insurance scheme for fare dodgers even
references the photo in its advertising
campaign armed with a hidden camera we
pay a visit to its office in Lea's in
northern France we ask if we're in the
right place
there's only two elements they don't
like you members pay 10 euros a month
into this clandestine scheme saving the
money they'd otherwise have to spend on
a monthly pass as well as any fines
incurred by fair dodging the numbers add
up it's not really above board but
journalist Olivia cos Amal believes that
there are core French values
underpinning the scheme people want
equality when it comes to public
transport that means that if one
neighborhood gets a new bus route than
every neighbourhood once won and people
want Liberty they want to be free to get
around if I'm broke I shouldn't have to
stay at home the Metro is going to run
whether I'm on it or not fair Dodgers
cost the French public transport system
an estimated 400 million euros a year
and that figure is rising a growing
number of people in France are doing it
I didn't have much money and there
aren't many controls so I rode without a
ticket but in the end it cost me 1,800
euros because I didn't pay the fines
right away and the charges kept going up
it's fair enough when young people are
broke they just mustn't get caught they
mustn't get caught by the police
Fair Dodgers have to be ready to take
the rough with the smooth
hole man and his friends have been
caught but they usually get away with it
I like feeling that I've stuck it to
them again here in France refusing to
pay for public transport is tantamount
to a political statement
you